[Musique]
je
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous racontent la vie
économique du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines pour ce numéro nous
sommes à magny les hameaux devant le
site du groupe colas colas filiale du
groupe bouygues spécialisée dans la
conception et l'entretien des
infrastructures de transport ici une
soixantaine de collaborateurs
travaillent sur les solutions de demain
concernant les infrastructures routières
des perspectives de développement
orientée plus vers les solutions bas
carbone pour réduire l'impact sur
l'environnement c'est au programme de ce
41e numéro du sky échos le groupe thales
a développé sur le site d'elancourt spy
ranger ce drone est utilisé par l'armée
de terre sur les théâtres d'opérations
spécialisé dans les infrastructures de
transport colas réfléchi aux solutions
pour développer les routes de demain une
réflexion menée sur le site de magny les
hameaux enfin retour sur deux
initiatives de formation organisé par
saint quentin en yvelines le sprint
comme pour le numérique et
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous et avant de
rentrer dans les détails regarder cette
présentation du groupe colas et du colas
research center de magny les hameaux
c'est une séquence avec le pdg du groupe
frédéric daerden
[Musique]
colas et hong hanh se définir comme le
leader mondial des infrastructures de
transport qui fait à peu près 13
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
60 mille employés et qui est actif en
france mais également dans 55 pays
l'international faisant à peu près 60 %
de notre chiffre d'affaires le site
magny les hameaux qui est le lieu où le
groupe concentre toute sa recherche et
développement toute l'innovation donc
elle est centrée sur la route mais
légalement centrée sur des innovations
de rupture liés aux infrastructures de
transport comme par exemple watts weck
est une solution de
photovoltaïque intégrée à la chaussée
ouf l'ol qui est une solution de
marquage dynamique de la chaussette le
défi d'un grand nombre de pays
industrialisés où nous travaillons c'est
de remonter la qualité des
infrastructures routières les routes en
france étaient en 2011 classé numéro 1
en termes de qualité dans le monde elles
sont passées en quelques années à la 17e
place il est urgent de ré investir de
l'argent dans la marque dans 0t faire
cette maintenance de façon intelligente
de façon prévisionnel avec une vision
globale sur le ca pour réduire les coûts
pour augmenter la qualité et pour
améliorer l'empreinte environnementale
qui ne peut qu être fait avec des
responsabilités globales sur la
maintenance routière
[Musique]
comme je vous le disais de nombreuses
innovations concernant les
infrastructures routières sont
développées ici au sein du corps de
colas et c'est le cas notamment de watou
et la route solaire ce sont des panneaux
photovoltaïques incrusté dans le
revêtement routier pour en parler nous
sommes avec davy michon bonjour bonjour
foyer bienvenu.merci nous accueillir
vous êtes responsable commercial de
watou et groupe colas
ou à tout et c'est quoi finalement boîte
ouais c'est quoi c'est une tare
vêtements photovoltaïque circulable donc
la prouesse technologique hommes du
groupe colas ça a été finalement de
pouvoir encapsulé une cellule
photovoltaïque dans des résines de
protection que l'on vient recouvrir
ensuite ici on le voit de granulats de
verre pour que cette ville soit
adhérentes et c'est infiniment un
revêtement qui permet de valoriser
l'espace public disponible là où il ya
finalement du parking disponibles du
trottoir on va pouvoir y ajouter un
revêtement photovoltaïques pour produire
de l'énergie solaire et utiliser cette
énergie solaire pour alimenter soit des
équipements soit faire de l'auto
consommation locale
l'histoire démarre en 2011 où nous
travaillons pendant quatre ans de 2011 à
2015 sur une première phase de r&d qui
va nous permettre de travailler avec le
cea tech et l'institut national de
l'énergie solaire qui est un organisme
mondialement reconnu et à l'issue de
cette r&d donc en 2015 on va sortir la
première dalle photovoltaïque premier
revêtement photovoltaîque circulade donc
watts wake dont vous avez un exemplaire
ici un échantillon et à partir de 2015
on va commencer des expérimentations
pendant trois à quatre ans donc jusqu'en
2018 2019 qui vont nous permettre de
pouvoir faire progresser au niveau
technique la dalle boîte web et de
débouchés à partir de 2019 donc sur une
première gamme qui va proposer quatre
solutions huawei et notamment donc de
deux solutions aujourd'hui qui sont
maintenant commercialisé donc une
première solution qui s'appelle loi tout
est pas qu elles nous permettent donc de
rendre autonome des petits équipements
tout autour de la voirie et puis une
seconde solution qu'on appelle de l'auto
consommation locale permettant
d'apporter de l'énergie à des clients
privés et publics ou est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver ces deux produits du coup dans
le monde je suppose parce que ça se fait
aussi à l'international alors en france
et international absolument
développement de ses deux deux solutions
donc aujourd'hui ou à tous et pâques est
une solution qui permet de rendre
autonome des équipements liés à la
mobilité douce par exemple on va pouvoir
alimenter des bornes de recharge vélo ou
de trottinettes et là on a des très bons
exemples aujourd'hui donc par exemple à
vauréal on attend en région parisienne
mais on a également à moosch dans le 49
voilà donc des abris vélos connectés
sécurisé et alimenté avec de la borne de
recharge vélo via la dengue watts way et
puis on peut également sécurisé des
passages piétons avec des petits
potelets lumineux qui vont nous
permettre valade d'illuminer un passage
piéton actuellement on a des exemples à
bonneuil sur marne en région parisienne
également
ou sur le conseil départemental du 44
donc ça voyez c'est très concret ces
sondes est aujourd'hui bien qui est
commercialisé avec des clients qui ont
fait le choix doit thouet et puis sur
l'auto consommation locale on a
également des solutions qui sont
développés alors en angleterre par
exemple la forme turn on a un centre de
tri aujourd'hui qui est alimentée avec
des al watwan mais également au japon où
on a un client japonais qui souhaite
pousser encore son mix énergétique qui
fait déjà du photovoltaïque
traditionnels et qui aujourd'hui rajoute
encore une solution photovoltaïque
nouvelle avec what was sur ces parkings
l'avenir pour moi tout et c'est quoi
alors on nous sommes très enthousiastes
et très confiant sur l'avenir
puisque toutes ces périodes itération
que nous avons quitté à partir de 2019
pour rentrer finalement dans une phase
de commercialisation nous ont permis de
progresser techniquement
et de pouvoir avoir une dalle qui est
donc plus résistantes qui produit 21 %
de plus qu elle ne produisait en 2018 et
à partir de 2019 changement de modèle on
va re modéliser la dalle qui va devenir
plus résistants qui va produire 21 % en
plus et puis aujourd'hui naissance d'une
dalle troisième génération plus grande
qui est le produit 156 watt crête est
donc cette période là maintenant on va
nous permettre de pouvoir travailler sur
la baisse des coûts et puis notre avenir
maintenant c'est de pouvoir répondre aux
enjeux environnementaux qui se
présentent devant nous on le voit avec
aujourd'hui donc des phénomènes
climatiques très important et donc
l'obligation d'avoir une neutralité
carbone très rapidement et puis de
pouvoir répondre aussi à l'enjeu de la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie et la
ouate way est finalement koch deux cases
fondamental pour notre avenir commun de
pouvoir finalement produire de l'énergie
sur de l'espace disponible sans faire de
mitage supplémentaires sont de
grignotage de l'espace supplémentaire et
donc je trouve que là où on a déjà dû
photovoltaïques traditionnels sur la
toiture et que l'on a de l'espace
disponible tel que des parkings et là je
pense
dc logisticiens des grands des soft
grandes surfaces commerciales par
exemple mais pas que eh bien on va
pouvoir utiliser cet espace disponible
pour pouvoir également installé une
solution photovoltaïque et produire de
l'énergie donc vous voyez on a un
certain enthousiasme une grande
confiance sur l'avenir de la technologie
watts web pour les années qui viennent
merci david michon merci à vous
responsable commercial ou à tous et
groupe colas et nous on va prendre la
direction maintenant du laboratoire du
corps et biens pour découvrir deux
nouvelles innovations concernant les
infrastructures routières
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le laboratoire du corps
le colas ricerche center avec myriam des
roches bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
c'est quoi le quotidien ici dans ce
laboratoire
alors essayez vous êtes au sein du pôle
chimie du corps center donc vous
rencontrez surtout des chimistes qui
travaillent soit sur l'assistance
technique à toutes nos filiales soit sur
des projets de recherche et
développement de nouveaux produits
procédés ou méthodes d'analysé vous avez
aussi un pôle matériaux qui gère plus
tous les essais sur les produits finis
et vous avez un pôle ingénierie et
dimensionnement qui travaillent sur le
calcul
enfin l'auscultation la modélisation etc
est l'une des innovations que vous
développez ici c'est végécol l'idée
c'est de remplacer le bitume par
finalement un enrobé disons avec de la
matière organique végétal c'est ça oui
c'est ça donc végécol c'est un enrobé
clair qui est fabriqué à partir d'un
lien ans d'origine végétale donc ce lien
il est fabriqué dans le sud de la france
et il est constitué de résine issus du
pain et d'huile obtenu à partir
d'oléagineux comment vous avez travaillé
sur ce projet comment vous l'avez
développer ici
alors c'est un sujet qui a été développé
en transverse donc toutes les tous les
différents acteurs du corps center ont
été mobilisés parce qu'il faut
travailler sur la chimie des matériaux
ensuite il faut les tester en conditions
réelles dans nos produits finis et puis
après il faut ausculté et évaluer
comment se comportent les produits sur
les sites puisque c'est toujours un peu
différent de ce qu'on voit en
laboratoire et donc il faut les suivre
au cours du temps donc on a deux cultes
à sion et de la modélisation pour
essayer de comprendre et de reproduire
les phénomènes en laboratoire et in
silico alors comment on fait pour passer
de ça à ça finalement c'est ça on dit
c'est là où j'ai envie de mordre dedans
c'est des barres de céréales alors c'est
un petit peu dur donc je vous
déconseille mais effectivement donc on
va venir travailler à une température
assez modérée on va chauffer l'huile on
va y ajouter de la résine et on obtient
donc ce lien c'est un lien en clair dont
qui permet de mettre en valeur la teinte
naturelle des granulats c'est ce qui
nous permet d'accéder donc à ce type
d'enrobé donc des enrobés clair comme
celui ci ou celui là après vous
choisissez les granulats les cailloux en
fonction de ce que vous voulez obtenir
comme comme l'esthétique et donc on peut
les utiliser dans des applications type
piste cyclable zone piétonne ou centres
urbains peut circuler est ce qu'on peut
imaginer par exemple remplacer
totalement le bitume par cette solution
mais partout pareil je pense notamment
aux autoroutes tout ça c'est ce sera
possible ou alors techniquement ça le
serait le la seule la seule limitation
c'est qu'on utilise des matières
premières à ces nobles pour faire ce
produit pour qu'il ait ce côté
esthétique dont on parlait et donc c'est
quand même dommage de mettre sur une
autoroute où vous allez avoir des
camions qui vont rouler chaque jour et
qui vont laisser des traces noires sur
le sur l'enrobé donc on va éviter on ira
plutôt chercher des produits justement
assez foncée et qui sont issus des
déchets donc des déchets végétaux pour
aller remplacer le bitume dans ce genre
d'application finalement ce qui change
c'est ce qui relie tous les cailloux
finalement c'est ça c'est ça donc là
vous avez la constitution d'un enrobé
donc complètement
éclatée pour bien voir ce qu'il ya
dedans donc vous avez les cailloux de
différentes tailles qui permettent de
constituer l'architecturé la structure
granulaire qui donne le corps de la
route et puis vous avez cette partie là
qui est le liant la colle qui permettent
d'assurer la cohésion de l'ensemble des
cailloux entre eux en fait et donc c'est
cette colle là qui est d'habitude du
bitume et qu'on remplace par des
produits issus des végétaux
donc ça c'est le liant chaud c'est ça se
dit un jour donc c'est ça une fois qu'il
est chaud on obtient cette consistance
de miel qui va permettre de
l'appliquer sur les granulats en faisant
une couche assez fine pour pas que ça
passe pour être un mode y est toujours
et pas de pain mais pas trop épaisses
justement pour que
pour qu'on n'ait pas trop non plus où
sous les soul et vous n'aurez dans la
thématique de la gourmandise quoi du
miel céréales un peu c'est un peu de
cuisine dans la chimie en fait
aujourd'hui moi ce qui est du bij école
à rentrer dans le monde dans le monde
même vous en trouvez à dolus d'oléron à
vedène à cuire à magny les hameaux
évidemment on en trouve aussi à la
réunion à rabat au maroc
on avait fait ces deux chantiers là
quand on était encore au stade
expérimental
pour avoir une idée de la tenue du
produit aux températures élevées
indice uv meehan des roches merci
beaucoup pour ses explications cette
démonstration aussi je rappelle que vous
êtes chef de projet chimie verte au sein
du groupe colas merci beaucoup de
plaisir et nous on va revenir sur le
salon international de la défense
eurosatory s'est déroulée du 13 au 17
juin dernier parmi les exposants il y
avait thales est thales a présenté son
spider un drone utilisés par l'armée de
terre et qui est développée à elancourt
regarder
[Musique]
le style rangers est un drone de
renseignement et de reconnaissance qui
est utilisé par les armées de terre et
notamment avoir un expert français c'est
un système de drones qui déploya blse
très facilement par deux opérateurs en
moins de dix minutes c'est un système
léger qui pèse à peu près 15 kilos et
qui doté d'une boule optronique
gyrostabilisée avec un capteur
infrarouge qui permet de voir la nuit et
un capteur aux définitions jours il est
aussi doté d'un pointeur laser qui
permet de désigner un objet d'intérêt
c'est un système qui fonctionne avec un
moteur électrique qui a une autonomie de
3 heures et qui a une réunion d'action
de 30 km le système de drones maintenant
est aussi utile qu'un qu'un fusil qu'une
tenue camouflée aucun casque c'est
l'oeil des portes et du soldat pourra
les voir à 10 20 30 km
ce système de drones est développé à
elancourt on s'appuie également sur
plusieurs pme françaises une qui dans le
sud de paris qui s'appelle aviation
design et une autre qui dans le sud de
la france qui s'appelle mériaux on fait
tout l'intégration système le
développement du drone le développement
de la partie qu'ils ont donné les
développements bien sûr de lâcher
l'image et de la boule optronique le
projet a démarré
début 2017 et il est actuellement en
phase de production et de livraison donc
on a livré plus d'une vingtaine de
systèmes à l'armée française ce système
étant équipé de trois drones
on se rend compte avec le contenu
craignant il ya une vraie un vrai enjeu
sur l'assurabilité des systèmes de
drones c'est à dire les aiderons doit
être capable de survivre dans un
environnement contesté à la fois en
termes de communication ou brouillées
communication pirates et drones on est
aussi en train de développer les futurs
briques qui vont être capables d'équiper
les spy rangers pour répondre à ces à
ces menaces
le spring camper l'entrepreneuriat pour
tous deux sessions de formation
organisées par saint quentin en yvelines
ces deux initiatives se sont conclues au
début du mois de juin retour sur ces
deux initiatives en images dans l'actuel
co
ans
[Musique]
en
community management et tout ce qui va
être communication sur les réseaux
sociaux cybersécurité c'est la personne
qui va contrôler le fait qu'ils aient
pas de piratage sur les systèmes web
designer c'est celui qui dessine en fait
les sites internet haliotis et donc
intelligence des objets c'est les objets
connectés des boîtes pour finir pour le
coup c c'est pas l'interface et le
codage c'est vraiment la construction
des sites
[Musique]
j'ai été aidé parce que je suis débutant
on apprend vraiment le numérique a suivi
de sept personnes un suivi individuel
que c'est vraiment bien fait bien
organisée je suis pas venu dans un but
très précis juste venu pour découvrir
les métiers du numérique je suis très
intéressé par le métier de webdesigner
et des web là je suis dans
l'approfondissement du métier de
webdesigner et je vais certainement
poursuivre bas par la formation de six
mois
[Musique]
j'ai créé une entreprise en tant
qu'assistante indépendante depuis
janvier qui a été immatriculé et l'idée
c'est pour accompagner des entrepreneurs
des chefs d'entreprise dans leur gestion
administrative
j'ai créé la société moderne comme il ya
un an environ moderne comme c'est une
micro entreprise c'est une agence de
communication qui propose de la
prestation de services dans la
communication et dans la gestion de la
communication en général mais digital en
particulier des petites entreprises et
moyennes entreprises
[Musique]
business plan étude de marché statut
juridique stratégie communication et
digital on a vraiment été encadrée et
vous est donné à un b à ba vraiment pour
débuter en toute connaissance de cause
quand j'ai regardé le programme il y
avait une formation condensé mais qui
répondait à toutes les attentes qu un
jeune entrepreneur ou un entrepreneur en
devenir peut avoir
la première promotion a suivi jusqu'au
bout la formation et nous avons eu six
créations à l'issue de cette formation
nous avons une nouvelle édition donc
l'appel à candidatures est en cours
jusqu'au 30 juin de la fin du mois à
l'issue il ya un jury de sélection début
juillet pour intégrer la promo dont qui
démarrera du 12 septembre 16 décembre
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez la revoir en
ripé sur notre site internet sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
là
oh
comment mais